мало але чудес донбас він відходить по
відома не проза померлих як учасники
бойових дити ким мирних жителів конфлікт
повернути зараз за своїми масштабами
це сигнал піку зараз у запеклих боїв
Церкви 2014 року уроку на засіданні раді
bespoke він ще до ситуації на сході
україни на прийду не завершився
безрезультатно
sd конфлікт конфлікт на сході України
3-го я вже третій рік мінську води так до
кінця і не реалізовано в крайньому обсязі дна
досягнуто прогресу для політичного
врегулювання конфлікту
прогресів темний майн lrf харчування
проведення виборів на непідконтрольних
Україні територіях, а ще до обміну
скроня виконана мем нехай і не зі
зустрічі в миску не дають результату з
механізм особливо рази ж новий правда
вгадуються всі сторони прямого
альтернатива тим формату поки що німа
сцена що автомобіль ще заповнюється та
до заповнюється та ін.
причому вони відразу мило в якому на премку
проблема пара горе у мінському форматі
тому в чому не відчайдушно
рішень
малюки мінімізують в витрати на бік спарень
з цим годинником плану з білизни кільки
зістригати і на сході України і
розрахунки на суму їхньої злочинності нині на
донбасі проти 700 постригу чого
чергує прибути окуляри сотні
спробуй за грози їх не можете все ще
високо бездіяльність їх теж був у я
за всі пропили ти вагоні ви постріл
зброю не і захочу чат та моніторингову
місію циви ікло духу або три мінських у
рік ланцюга дрова і сушилися прямого не на
стабілізацію ситуації поставити під
загрозу ви куна ними тиках догляд україну
свою чергу на полях та на розміщення з
бруно і місіс постригати його так званих
днр та лнр
а швидко розумова для безтурботного правда
не виборі 1 куб хвилі такого вирішеного
ніж години матчу в ти не в роті і він і
мандат спеціальної моніторингової місії
обсі продовжено ще нарік і буде зради
у мандаті місії
вимагають нового рішення, що належить
тусим від йшла нам rbc щоб рудь долею
процесі пукаєш в організацію рубля
ставку на покращення технічних можливостей
ввести місії за крему для
аерофотозйомки космічної зйомки та
інших повії
моніторингу ситуації